il est l'heure de la question du jour
bienvenue aujourd'hui le Figaro vous
demande de répondre OUI ou NON à ceci
l'équipe de France sera-t-elle sacrée
championne du monde face à l'Argentine
vous étiez sûrement devant votre télé ce
mercredi soir pour regarder les Bleus
l'emporter face au Maroc et maintenant
la marche la plus haute la finale face à
l'Argentine du plus grand joueur du 21e
siècle un certain Lionel Messi Baptiste
des prés bonjour bonsoir vous êtes en
direct depuis DOA l'un de nos envoyer
merci merci bonsoir à tous bon Baptiste
vous êtes remis des émotions de cette
demi-finale ou pas encore
nous on est comme les joueurs on a déjà
basculé sur sur la suite sur sur la
finale on est ultra professionnel on
pense qu'à ça on pense qu'elle a fait
mal mais effectivement c'était quand
même une belle soirée une grande soirée
pour être tout à fait honnête et
transparent on a on a transpiré on a
stressé jusqu'au bout avec cette équipe
de France c'était un match assez âpre
assez intense et difficile surtout très
indécis face au Maroc il faut saluer le
parcours des Lions de l'Atlas qui ont
été fabuleux qui ont été héroïques
maintenant oui on bascule sur
l'Argentine et vous l'avez dit face au
sans doute le plus grand joueur du monde
ou en tout cas du 21e siècle Lionel
Messi ça s'annonce passionnant et
grandiose vous réagissez évidemment sur
Le Figaro.fr sur Youtube je prends vos
questions je les transmets à Baptiste
vous avez réussi à vibrer hier soir
est-ce que ça fait vraiment une une tête
de demi-finale c'était pas un grand
match et avec le Maroc qui n'est pas une
équipe historique à ce stade de la
compétition vous avez réussi à sentir
vous dans le stade l'effet demi-finale
ou pas vraiment
bah il suffisait d'arriver au stade
comme on l'a fait deux trois heures
avant voir c'est toute cette horde de
supporters marocain débarqué c'était une
vraie marée rouge au stade d'albach qui
est situé en gros une cinquantaine de
kilomètres de Doha dans le désert
qatari et oui on a oui on a réussi à
vibrer parce que c'était un une
demi-finale de Coupe du monde qu'il faut
pas galvauder vous l'avez dit le Maroc
et pas un client habitué à ce stade de
la compétition mais en revanche dès que
vous mettiez un pied dans le stade à
savoir aussi lors de l'annonce des
compositions d'équipe avec les joueurs
français
U et Mbappe énormément Hué plus derrière
l'entrée sur le terrain l'échauffement
le match en tant que tel qui était pas
un grand match en termes de côté
spectaculaire c'était pas fabuleux mais
le scénario était assez dingue
l'intensité était là l'agressivité était
là et rien que pour ça oui c'était un
vrai match de Coupe du Monde et une
vraie demi-finale oui bien entendu on va
évidemment se projeter maintenant sur
cette finale face à l'Argentine on
parlera de l'adversaire mais on parle
des Bleus d'abord alors Mathis j'arrive
pas à savoir si cette équipe est
normalement faible pour atteindre une
finale ou au contraire incroyablement
sur d'elle sur de sa force pour ne faire
que le service minimum votre avis
là-dessus
Thibault n'est pas faible quand on est
en finale de Coupe du Monde 4 ans après
sur le toit du monde en russe il y a
plus d'une équipe qui s'est qui sait
cassé la figure au premier tour en étant
tenant du titre sur les cinq dernières
éditions Les Quatre
tenants du site sont sortis dès le
premier tour donc c'est vous dire
l'exploit de l'équipe de France il faut
surtout pas le banaliser et dans votre
petite question je sens un petit truc
comme ça là ça ça me plaît pas trop Tibo
non mais pour pour être tout à fait
sérieux c'est non si vous avez raison ce
qu'ils ont fait les joueurs de Didier
Deschamps c'est c'est assez dingue et il
faut surtout pas galvauder une place en
finale ça se trouve vous comme moi on
enverra pas d'autres non c'est pas
totalement mais il faut profiter il faut
savourer et surtout il faut saluer quand
même fait de Didier Deschamps et de ses
joueurs qui 4 ans après avoir été en
finale de la Coupe du Monde 2018 ils
sont à nouveau contre l'Argentine on va
est déjà monumental est-ce que
d'ailleurs on a une idée est-ce qu'on
peut dire que cette équipe est
supérieure ou inférieur cette équipe de
France à celle de 2018 selon vous
Baptiste
écoutez on va on va on va attendre de
voir dimanche soir ce qui va se passer
mais si je devais vous répondre
aujourd'hui moi je trouve qu'elle est un
peu inférieure quand même à par rapport
à 2018 parce que 2018 c'était un rouleau
compresseur c'était quand même une
équipe qui avait très peu de failles sur
a été ils étaient fabuleux il y avait un
bloc c'était redouté par tout le monde
là aujourd'hui c'est une équipe de
France assez imparfaite finalement parce
que elle ne maîtrise pas tout elle a des
temps faibles dans ces dans ces
différents matchs on l'a vu contre le
Maroc on l'a vu contre l'Angleterre mais
à côté de ça elle a une force offensive
et surtout des talents dans toutes les
parties du terrain on pense hier soir
quand même qu'il y a même bapé qui a pas
été extraordinaire sur un coup de rein
il change la il change la fin de match
on pense à Antoine Griezmann qui est
fabuleux aussi le début de la
compétition Olivier Giroud qui marque
débute en Coupe du Monde Raphaël Varane
Hugo Lloris donc elle est peut-être
moins moins souveraine mais elle est
dotée d'une force de caractère qui peut
lui permettre de rêver vraiment à une
troisième étoile dimanche soir je me dis
je vous transmets ce que me dit Bocar il
ressemble à Messi oui c'est vrai qu'avec
votre barbe Baptiste pour y ressembler à
Lionel Messi je suis pas sûr que vous
ayez le même placement de jambes tiens
vous m'avez parlé de Kylian Mbappé que
se passe-t-il avec le la star des Bleus
euh ça va pour lui ça fait deux matchs
qui il est un peu en dessous non alors
on sait que sur un éclair de génie peut
faire la différence et vous l'avez dit
mais est-ce que hier en conférence de
presse on a senti on a posé des
questions au sujet de la star de Bondy
et moi je trouve ça plutôt pas mal ce
qui se passe autour de lui qu'il vient
map dans le sens où ça permet de pas
galvauder ce qui ce qui fait
habituellement les standards qu'il a
sont exceptionnels les buts qu'il a
marqué au premier tour on l'a vu en
difficulté contre contre l'Angleterre on
l'a vu aussi en difficulté contre le
Maroc mais à côté de ça sur un éclair de
génie notamment en fin de match il est
il est quand même décisif à deux
reprises hier soir il fait pas un bon
match mais il fait quand même par son
boulot gagner les Bleus donc ça c'est
c'est vraiment à mettre un son crédit et
ça montre aussi une chose c'est que il a
fait peur à tout le monde et au monde
entier avec son premier tour XXL il a
fait peur aussi en 8e de finale avec ses
bulles contre la Pologne et aujourd'hui
qu'il y a Mbappe quand on est du stade
je sais pas quel est l'impression
derrière votre poste de télévision mais
il y a deux trois quatre joueurs qui
sont sur Killian Mbappe ça reste un
humain ça reste un joueur avec 4 garçons
sur lui c'est beaucoup plus difficile
mais il permet aussi de faire des
décalages ou autre donc non il y a
aucune inquiétude à avoir autour de
Kylian Mbappe mais c'est simplement que
derrière tout le monde est sur lui il a
trois quatre joueurs et c'est pas non
plus un surhomme je vous rappelle la
question du jour l'équipe de France
sera-t-elle sacrée championne du monde
face à l'Argentine on attend encore un
peu avant de découvrir la réponse de nos
internautes tiens j'ai une question de
Sam V Adrien rabiot sera de retour
dimanche point d'interrogation il y a
une inquiétude autour d'Adrien Rabi on
se demande rassurez-moi est-ce qu'il a
le covid Adrien rabiot parce que ça
pourrait impacter tout le vestiaire des
Bleus là Baptiste
officiellement non il a été
effectivement malade cette semaine il
est resté à l'hôtel hier soir il a même
pas fait le déplacement au cours des
placements d'une cinquantaine de
kilomètres comme je vous le disais il
est resté au sein de l'établissement
pour suivre le match des Bleus il a
accueilli ses partenaires aussi hier
soir mais Adrien rabiot normalement de
des retours qu'on a va beaucoup mieux
déjà aujourd'hui et ce réape pour le
match contre contre l'Argentine parce
qu'il a énormément manqué hier et
surtout il sera très attendu et très
important dans sa dans sa faculté à
pouvoir défendre sur Lionel Messi parce
qu'il va être dans sa zone ça va être un
duel extraordinaire parce qu'Adrien
rabiot depuis le début de la compétition
et sans doute l'un des meilleurs joueurs
de cette équipe de France il resplendit
totalement ici au Qatar et face à un
client comme Messi on va avoir besoin
d'un rabio à 200% vous avez raison de
parler de Lionel Messi Baptiste on y
vient parce que c'est évidemment le duel
que tout le monde attend bapé Messi
est-ce qu'on pouvait rêver mieux
franchement que un affrontement entre
ces deux joueurs
mais non c'est une affiche de rêve on a
la France contre l'Argentine c'est
l'Argentine c'est un mythe du football
mondial on a deux équipes qui qui vont
batailler pendant 90 voir 120 minutes
pour une troisième étoile on a
l'Argentine 85 depuis Maradona en 86 on
a Messi qui dispute sa dernière Coupe du
monde on est des chanceux très
sincèrement Thibault parce qu'on va voir
Lionel Messi face à Kilian Mbappe mais
c'est qui s'apprête à faire sa dernière
finale de Coupe du Monde c'est l'artiste
une dernière danse une dernière entrée
sur scène et on attend ça avec avec
impatience et quand on voit la ferveur
l'amour de tous les supporters argentins
qui sont là en nombre ils sont entre 30
et 50 000 à chaque match je sais pas si
vous vous rendez compte alors que nous
en France on a à peine 3000 ils ont ils
débarquent en masse et ça va être
extraordinaire et DOA dimanche ce sera
Buenos Aires est-ce que justement la
France est plus forte que la légende que
le destin vous voyez ce que je veux dire
s'il faudra battre plus que l'Argentine
et Messi parce que tout le monde veut et
peut-être que les dieux du foot veulent
que Lionel Messi un jour champion du
monde est-ce que ça peut trop t'aider
dans la tête des Bleus est-ce que ça
peut être une pression supplémentaire
finalement mais si en face peut devenir
champion du monde et peut-être le plus
grand joueur de l'histoire en gagnant
cette Coupe du monde
bien sûr que ce sera une pression
supplémentaire parce que quand vous
affrontez Lionel Messi avec l'Argentine
ce maillot mythique que tout le monde
connaît on sait à quoi s'attendre elle
est bleue le savent pertinemment la
question était posée hier à Didier
Deschamps conférence de presse est-ce
qu'il y a un plan antimés ici alors il a
répondu avec un sourire en disant que
toutes les équipes depuis au moins 15
ans ont un plan anti Messie mais
personne n'a vraiment trouvé donc il
s'agira de réduire la zone d'activité de
du du de la légende Argentine mais après
derrière ça va être compliqué mais c'est
pour ça que Adrien rabiot serait très
important parce que il sera dans la zone
du de l'Argentin et on attend beaucoup
de drabion on attend beaucoup de
d'Hernandez et on attend beaucoup de
doupe à mécano si il est là mais mais
oui c'est une affiche de rêve parce que
Messi encore une fois dernière finale de
Coupe du monde
on attend ça vraiment avec avec
impatience et quand on voit le tous les
supporters argentins qui ne pensent et
qui ne voient que par Messi ça annonce
un spectacle vraiment grandiose les
supporters et les joueurs on va parler
dans un instant mais d'abord Baptiste
répondez vous aussi à cette question du
jour l'équipe de France sera-t-elle
sacrée championne du monde face à
l'Argentine oui non vous me donnez le
petit plus le petit bémol et puis après
on clique pour voir ce qu'on pense nos
internautes
moi je dis oui oui je l'espère forcément
en tant que en tant que en tant que
supporter de foot en tant que
journaliste aussi l'équipe de France
réussit ça à vraiment entrer encore un
peu plus dans la légende parce qu'ils
sont déjà maintenant les Bleus sont
favoris ça clairement parce que quand
vous êtes tenant du titre quand vous
avez un bac Giroud Griezmann enfin
toutes ces cités avec Lloris qui
débarque sur le terrain vous avez quand
même des talents qui sont colossaux mais
ce sera compliqué parce que l'Argentine
du début de compétition n'est plus du
tout la même il y a quelque chose de
d'irrationnel dans cette équipe portée
par Messi avec l'ombre de Maradona on
l'a dit avec les supporters donc ce sera
très compliqué mais pour moi l'équipe de
France est favorite alors allons-y
cliquons sur Oui et regardons ce qu'on
pense nos nos internautes du Figaro
cette question depuis hier oui pour
l'instant vous pensez que la France va
l'emporter à 69,12% ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle évidemment et c'est à peu près
la même chose sur le chat sur sur
Youtube encore quelques secondes
ensemble artiste il y a un concours de
meilleur buteur tiens mais si bah P5
buts chacun et puis il y a l'autre
joueur
argentin Rulian Alvarez qui a quatre
buts comme Olivier Giroud ça c'est une
compétition dans la compétition non
exactement et ça ajoute encore un peu de
piment et un peu de sel à cette finale
qui n'en manque pas on l'a dit de
nations mythique du football et là on a
Messi face à Mbappe le jeune face au
face au vieux entre guillemets on a les
seconds couteaux Alvarez et Giraud qui
peuvent aussi coiffer les stars on sait
jamais un jour un doublé de de Giroud
dimanche et ça y est il est lui qui
était vilipendé il y a encore quelques
mois il est meilleur buteur de cette
coupe du monde donc ça s'annonce ça
s'annonce fabuleux il y a plein de
matchs dans le match on l'a dit
rabiométie Mbappe Mbappé Messi tout
tournera autour de ça et on attend
vraiment avec impatience on est que on
est que quoi on est que jeudi c'est
encore dimanche donc il y a encore un
petit peu de temps d'ici là on va suivre
l'équipe de France et les Bleus mais on
a hâte d'être à dimanche après-midi au
stade de l'ouzailles oui Vivement
dimanche comme dit certains cette équipe
d'Argentine j'ai l'impression que les
joueurs ne sont pas là pour devenir
champion du monde ils sont là pour
accompagner mais si elle devient on les
a vu chanter dans les vestiaires des
champs en disant je suis né sur la même
terre que Diego un peu Maradona et la
même terre que Lionel que Léo Lionel
Messi c'est absolument incroyable vous
imaginez les joueurs de l'équipe de
France se mettent dans le sillage de
Mbappé par exemple c'est inconcevable en
France
mais c'est hallucinant et ça montre le
poids et l'aspect légendaire de Lionel
Messi vous l'avez dit il est en tout cas
il veut s'inscrire dans les pas de Diego
Maradona qui a été champion du monde en
86 et c'est le c'est le rat ultime pour
Messi qui a gagné un paquet de Ballon
d'Or qui a gagné des Ligues des
Champions il a il a plus besoin de ça
entre guillemets et si c'est sa dernière
danse il est là pour ça et c'est assez
marrant et assez bluffant quand on est
au stade et qu'on suit les matchs de
l'Argentine ce qu'on a pu faire depuis
le début de la compétition c'est que
Lionel Messi que ce soit sur ou en
dehors du terrain il a ses lieutenant à
savoir que dès qu'il se passe quelque
chose autour de lui dès qu'un adversaire
vient un peu lui chatouiller les jambes
ce qui arrive très fréquemment des
canadversaire vient du chuchoter à
l'oreille des canadaire vient un petit
peu le pousser le bousculer il a tout de
suite quelqu'un que ce soit par edès ou
de Paul ou d'autres ou d'autres joueurs
qui viennent un peu comme des gardes du
corps et dire attention tu touches pas à
l'idole tu touches pas la légende et
quand le temps de partir en début de
match notamment pour pour l'échauffement
c'est assez dingue parce que à chaque
fois le même cérémonial ils arrivent ils
forment un V lui à la pointe de Sv
entre sur le terrain et l'acclamation
est totale avec des supporters argentins
qui sont en transe il faut vraiment être
là pour pour le croire c'est assez
fabuleux et incroyable de voir ça et il
y a une part d'irrationnelle comme vous
l'avez dit autour de ces joueurs
argentins et de ce peuple argentin qui
font corps derrière un seul et même
joueur à savoir Lionel Messi j'ai deux
questions vous avez 30 secondes par
question Baptiste pas plus les points
faibles de l'Argentine on l'a bien
compris mais si Messi Messi ça c'est
l'immense point fort les points faibles
de cette équipe
les points faibles de cette équipe c'est
la lenteur de sa défense au niveau du
coup de pied arrêté de manière aérien je
pense qu'Olivier Giroud peut leur faire
mal même Raphaël Varane mais c'est
surtout la lenteur de la défense donc
est-ce que les Argentins seront à 5
derrière avec Mbappé ça peut faire mal
ok dernière question elle concerne les
bleus j'ai l'impression qu'on fait pas
beaucoup de changements est-ce que les
joueurs sont fatigués un seul changement
contre l'Angleterre deux changements
seulement hier soir est-ce qu'on peut
gagner une Coupe du monde à 11 ou
presque et puis c'est tout ou est-ce que
les Bleus je pense Olivier Giroud
notamment sont peut-être un peu crevés
là maintenant aujourd'hui
pour assurer un peu les fans et les
supporters de Livier Giroud les infos
qu'on a eu nous ce matin c'est que
Olivier Giroud fera tout pour être la
dimanche il avait un petit peu mal au
genou mais normalement ça devrait passer
et oui les remplaçants il y en a peu on
l'a vu Didier Deschamps comptent sur 13
14 joueurs maximum mais en revanche dès
que vous faites rentrer quelqu'un on
pense à Randall Colomiers qui rentrent
et premier ballon premier but pourvu que
ça dure pour l'équipe de France et vous
avez pas besoin d'être 23 joueurs pour
gagner une finale demain dimanche pardon
merci beaucoup merci Baptiste merci à
Vincent roseron qui était derrière la
caméra vous êtes depuis dehors on se
retrouve dimanche évidemment pour la
grande soirée dans le salon du Figaro
autour de cette finale de la Coupe du
Monde merci à tous les deux profiter
bien merci de nous avoir aidés à mieux
répondre à cette question du jour
l'équipe de France sera-t-elle sacrée
championne du monde face à l'Argentine
la suite de la soirée sur le figure live
c'est point de vue dans quelques minutes
c'est avec le dia Cohen et puis à 20h le
club idées du Figaro Eugénie Bastié vous
attend avec de grandes questions autour
de la place du christianisme en France
merci de nous avoir suivi vous restez
évidemment connecter au Figaro live sur
le site sur Youtube plein de choses à
vous montrer excellente soirée sur notre
antenne salut